[Music]
[Music]
the triforce has become one of the most
famous video game symbols of all time
imagine that putting three triangles
together and pretty much everyone out
there knows exactly where it comes from
the british third army division founded
in 1809 by arthur wellesley first duke
of wellington
ok yeah nintendo definitely wasn't the
first to come up with the design but in
the world of gaming it has become
synonymous with the zelda series but
where did the inspiration for the
triforce come from i have a particular
gripe with this subject and it's not
because it's still a bit of a mystery to
this day but in fact that people pretend
that it isn't i've been wanting to do a
video about the origins of the triforce
for a while now and essentially canceled
the idea because well the mystery was
already solved or so i was led to
believe but after a bit of digging you
quickly realize that nintendo has never
outright confirmed anything when it
comes to where they got the idea from
the conclusion presented is simply a
best guess and not a solid fact at all a
very good best guess mind you but i've
always felt there was something missing
so before we get into what the main
consensus is let's do a little
backtracking first
1986 nintendo releases the first game in
the zelda franchise simply titled the
legend of zelda the game itself barely
showcased any story at all except for a
very brief introduction text which can
only be seen if you leave the title
screen on idle for about 10 seconds the
only other piece of story exposition was
saved for the game's manual two whole
pages in fact by the way great choice of
text color and background guys i guess
this was before readability became a
thing anyway back then there were only
two triforce pieces power and wisdom
power being in the possession of ganon
and wisdom having been separated into
eight pieces and hidden across hyrule by
zelda nowhere does it ever state that a
third triforce piece exists it just says
the legend of the triforce golden
triangles possessing mystical powers and
on page 10 it reads link has destroyed
ganon and has managed to rescue princess
zelda now that he's got a hold of the
two triforces he once again goes on his
travels towards countries unknown notice
also how they use the word triforces
plural to describe the two triangles
nowadays they usually don't do that
anymore and all three pieces combined
are referred to as the triforce whereas
individually they are either called a
triforce piece or simply by their virtue
like triforce of power or triforce of
wisdom oh and just in case you're
wondering the japanese version is almost
identical the biggest difference being
that here it's not the legend of the
triforces that's being passed down but
the objects themselves what followed was
zelda 2 the adventure of link this game
shows the first depiction of the
triforce symbol as we know it today but
not in the actual game itself oh no it
barely misses the mark on that one
the only time we see it as one entity is
again in the game's manual and not even
the relic itself but in the form of a
mark on the back of link's hand this is
the first time that a third piece of the
triforce is mentioned and obtaining it
is the main goal of the story but i said
before the three pieces never combined
into a single entity in game and remain
disconnected from each other then came a
link to the past and the first time we
see the triforce in its full glory
suddenly the symbol as we know it today
was all over the place as soon as you
boot up the game the logo prologue on
shields statues in the ending cutscene
and of course in the manual it's also
here that we see the first iteration of
a backstory for the triforce in zelda 1
and 2 this was never touched upon it
just said it had mystical powers but
didn't explain where they came from or
what these powers are exactly a link to
the past essentially cemented to
triforce as the three-part wish-granting
all-powerful relic created by the gods
we are all familiar with and from here
on out this narrative would largely
remain the same with some extra lore
being added here and there so with that
said what is the main consensus when it
comes to the inspiration behind the
triforce well in a nutshell its origin
can be traced back to the family crest
or mon from the hojo clan it's a family
that played a crucial role in medieval
japan most famous for their successful
opposition to the mongol invasions of
japan and fostering zen buddhism across
the country the crest itself originates
from a legend where the head of the
family tokimasa hojo went to visit a
dragon deity on the island of enoshima
to pray for the prosperity of his
descendants the dragon answered and left
behind three scales which together
formed the mitsuroko which translates to
three scales this legend may have also
been the inspiration for the three
dragons in breath of the wild as they
too leave behind the scale but i digress
up until the zelda series brought the
triforce into our pop culture the symbol
of the mitsuroko was relatively obscure
in the west but in japan it has
persisted for centuries many families
adapted a similar symbol as their crest
and it can still be found in japanese
graveyards today including the grave of
gunpei yokoi inventor of the original
gameboy who tragically died in a car
accident in 1997. he's also described as
having been a mentor for suguru miyamoto
the visionary for super mario and the
zelda series this has caused some to
believe that the inclusion of the
triforce symbol was an homage to his
mentor who would have still been alive
at that point as he died only a mere
month before the release of ocarina of
time there's also an important deity
named ben zaitan who serves as both a
buddhist goddess as well as a shinto
kami there are multiple shrines devoted
to her including in and around the city
of kyoto some of which depict a
triforce-like symbol as well and
miyamoto has expressed that he likes to
visit these kinds of shrines aside from
that the mitsuroko is also found in the
corporate world like the japanese energy
company mitsuroko so yeah miyamoto would
have no doubt been well aware of the
existence of this icon as it's part of
japanese culture and history but as far
as i'm aware he's never publicly stated
whether he took the inspiration straight
from the history of the hojo family or
if it was an homage to yokoi's family
crest or if he just simply looked at his
energy bill one day and was like yes
either way it doesn't really matter as
ultimately it all links back to the hojo
legend some claim he did make a
statement about it and if that's the
case please provide me with a source i
have looked everywhere and i cannot find
it so given all i've just outlined i
think it's safe to say that yes the
mitsuroko was most likely the
inspiration for the triforce as we know
it today the case closed right well
here's the thing though while it does
explain why the triforce looks the way
it does now is this really the true
origin of the relic because remember the
triforce didn't show up until zelda 2's
manual and didn't make a full-on
appearance in-game until a link to the
past if the idea for the triforce was
always there and based on the mitsuroko
symbol why was it completely absent from
the first zelda and not just from the
game itself but promotional art
commercials and anything else related to
the game well i believe that initially
there may have been a different
inspiration for the triforce one that
would later be changed as the series
continued let me demonstrate what i mean
although the zelda series was created in
japan and by a japanese company it's
become obvious that the series was
initially inspired by a lot of western
ideas and catered towards a western
audience we can see this fact pop up
again and again in the game itself
artwork interviews with the series
creators and even the music the first
and obvious one that most people know by
now is that the name of the princess as
well as the series as a whole is named
after american writer and painter zelda
fitzgerald because miyamoto thought the
name sounded elegant but that's just the
tip of the iceberg in the nes original
the book of magic resembles a standard
depiction of the holy book of
christianity the bible with a cross on
the cover and in the japanese version of
the game the book of magic is literally
called bible furthermore we find many
cross symbolism on shields enemies and
graves all throughout the first two
games and zelda 2 the adventure of link
even sees the cross as a quest item it
allows link to see enemies which appear
as invisible without it and navigate the
valley of death another clear reference
to the christian faith this also applies
to ganon himself nowadays he's mostly
described as the demon king or king of
evil or something along those lines but
back then he was referred to as the
prince of darkness which is one of many
titles commonly used to address the
devil what's weird is that they didn't
censor this in the opening crawl but did
remove it in some parts of the manual
for some reason even hyrule itself its
culture and architecture is confirmed to
be based on medieval europe as stated by
hidemaru fujibayashi the opening title
music of the first game was originally
supposed to be an 8-bit rendition of a
classical song called bolero by french
composer maurice revell however right
before the release of zelda 1 it turned
out that the song was still copyrighted
and thus the series composer koji kondo
pulled an all-nighter to compose an
original song which came to be the
iconic zelda theme we all know and love
during an interview to celebrate the
release of the nes classic miyamoto even
made the remark that at the time the
song reminded him of spaghetti western
movies speaking of miyamoto in the same
interview he was also asked why he
decided to make the legend of zelda
series at the time and his answer was
simply the indiana jones movies were out
at the time and continues on to say that
he wanted to bring that sense of
adventure to a video game if you know
anything about the indiana jones movies
you know that it features a lot of
western mythology particularly
christianity like the ark of the
covenant the cross of coronado the holy
grail and so on basically what i'm
saying is that miyamoto has since the
beginning of his career been inspired by
these kinds of themes and the same goes
for takashi tezuka he is i guess one of
the lesser known figures from the zelda
development history but equally as
important as he was the director and is
considered to be the father of the zelda
storyline in the early 2d era prior to
zelda he and miyamoto made a game called
devil world which was never released in
the u.s for
obvious reasons it too features holy
crosses and well
the devil safe to say that the two were
definitely no stranger to taking
inspiration from this kind of subject
matter it's actually a bit ironic if you
think about it nintendo tried to appeal
to a western audience by putting in all
sorts of references to their most
prominent religion but it sort of had
the opposite effect and a lot of it
ended up getting censored to avoid
controversy even to this day nintendo of
america still removes or changes certain
words or phrases especially things
regarding demons or the demon tribe
check out this video by quest with aaron
if you want to see just how much the
english translation differs in some
cases nowadays a lot of people refer to
shintoism as one of the more prominent
influences for the series lore but that
didn't really start becoming a
noticeable thing until later which is
why i find it a bit difficult to believe
that the triforce was always meant to be
based on japanese mythology even though
almost everything else was clearly based
on christianity to some degree there
aren't a lot of quotes from the game's
developers about the triforce in the nes
era though miyamoto has revealed one
interesting thing about it since namely
that the original zelda was supposed to
feature elements of science fiction the
pieces of the triforce link collects
were meant to be microchips and link
would travel between the past and the
future and not like ocarina of time and
its seven year time gap but like the
matrix type of future and he closes by
saying but in the end link never went to
the future and it remained a heroic
fantasy game we can even say that there
was absolutely nothing futuristic
another example of the uncertainty that
existed back in the late 80s regarding
what exactly the triforce was supposed
to be is found in the legend of zelda
cartoon from 1998. of course this isn't
canon to the series lore but it is
obvious that the creators of the show
try to interpret and adapt as much of
the original source material as they
possibly could from link's abilities to
the sound effects the enemies ganon etc
and when it comes to the triforce you
can see that there wasn't really a good
understanding yet regarding its origin
abilities and overall lore here too only
two parts of the triforce exist one in
zelda's possession and one in the hands
of ganon similar to the first game and
the entire plot revolves around ganon
trying to get his hands on both and
conquer hyrule they don't resemble
anything close to the modern day
triforce at all and are instead upside
down pyramids and possess the power of
speech it's also worth mentioning that
although the series was made and
published by a third party it was
overseen by nintendo of america so let's
say the first iteration of the triforce
wasn't based on the hojo legend and the
mitsuroko symbolism then what's the
alternative given the track record of
influences from christianity in the
early games i'd say this might apply to
the triforce as well obviously i cannot
prove anything since there are simply no
sources to fall back on but my best
guess is that it may have been based on
the equilateral triangle a symbol
associated with the holy trinity of the
father the son and the holy spirit i do
have to mention that this depiction
isn't universal throughout all of
christianity and not all depictions of
this are still accepted today it kind of
depends on who you ask and which branch
of christianity you would use as a
reference but in some cases imagery of
one or more golden triangles are used to
represent the trinity so i don't think
it's out of the realm of possibility
that someone from the original zelda
team whether it was miyamoto or tezuka
took inspiration from these depictions
it would fall in line with all the other
christian references and the triforce
was sort of a god-like relic with
mystical powers a more boring
alternative would be that the triforce
took on the shape of a yellow triangle
because it was simply an easy shape to
use given the graphical limitations at
the time i mean there's only so many
primitives you can choose from so maybe
it was just a random choice which
coincidentally fit well with the later
ideas behind the triforce one could of
course make the case that nintendo chose
a triangle because they were always
planning to someday merge three of them
together to form the mitsuroku symbol
which is possible the original creators
were hoping that they could continue the
series after the first game but at the
same time i just don't see nintendo
planning a road map that far ahead i
mean the zelda timeline is kind of a
testament to that especially considering
they couldn't have known how big and
successful the zelda series would become
in the future the original lore was
vague and lacked a lot of exposition and
backstory if there was an elaborate plan
for the series laura at this point i
would honestly be very impressed as the
series progressed nintendo slowly
started doing away with a lot of
real-life religious references in favor
of their own original lore as well as
elements from japanese mythology this
became especially noticeable with
skyward sword and recently breath of the
wild and it's definitely not an uncommon
thing to do as an example miyazaki also
started his career being heavily
inspired by european architecture and
settings only to bring in more and more
japanese influences later on zelda was
intended to be a classic medieval
adventure story with a lot of
inspiration from western mythology and
religion but slowly veered off into its
own direction as it became increasingly
successful of course everything we've
discussed here today is in regards to
the aesthetics of the triforce when it
comes to its actual inner workings and
mythology well
that is a whole different story
altogether there's definitely a lot to
explore here as well but that's too big
for one video and perhaps i will dig
into this as well someday as always i
highly encourage a good and healthy
discussion in the comments below if you
have your own ideas or found interesting
details about the subject don't shy away
from sharing them with me and others or
if you're just here to chime in about
anything else zelda related or just here
to say hi that is of course more than
welcome too a big thanks to you for
watching to my mods both on discord and
my streams and of course to my patreons
and channel members who remain ever so
generous oh and apparently my channel
has been blessed with a new beta
functionality which allows you to make a
one-time donation a bit like a super
chat but for an individual video so if
you want to support the channel
financially but you don't want to commit
to a membership this is a nice
alternative though never feel obligated
to do so your support as a viewer is
already greatly appreciated and that is
all for now this is dawn signing off and
have a good one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you